was müssen wir bei der nutzung der app
beachten darüber spreche ich jetzt mit
sven stein aus unserem digital ressort
herzlich willkommen es wenn bei uns im
studio ja worauf müssen nutzer denn
jetzt achten nicht dass es wieder
passiert dass die fünf wochen lang nicht
anschlägt also das wichtigste ist jetzt
natürlich für betroffene nutzer und das
sind die die geräte von samsung und
huawei und möglicherweise auch andere
geräte mit dem android betriebssystem
haben dass die dafür sorgen dass die app
jetzt auf dem aktuellsten stand ist die
neueste version der app wurde ja
vorgestern abend veröffentlicht und die
nutzer sollten also jetzt ganz dringend
diese aktualisierung auch vornehmen
technik bleibt ja einfach auch technik
müssen wir damit rechnen dass hier immer
mal wieder was schief geht
naja wenn programme programmiert werden
wenn wenn technik vor dem programmiert
wird müssen wir immer davon ausgehen
dass irgendwo sich ein fehler
einschleicht und in diesem fall ist es
ja noch nicht mal ein fehler der direkt
in der app nicht sondern der also quasi
in dem system nicht auf dem die app
aufsetzt und man wird solche fehler
natürlich immer wieder haben und man
muss dann eben entsprechend reagieren
und aktiv auch darauf hinweisen dass es
dieses problem gibt um zumindest die
probleme dadurch zu minimalisiert ja wie
kann man denn solche fehler in der
zukunft vermeiden und worauf muss ich
auf meinem smartphone den achten gibt es
da gewisse einstellungen die ich mich
kümmern muss damit diese app wirklich
auch funktioniert also das wichtigste
ist halt dass die sogenannte hintergrund
aktualisierung bei dieser app
funktioniert man muss sich klar machen
die app ist dazu da uns zu warnen wenn
wir uns eine gewisse zeit in der nähe
von einem corona infizierten aufgehalten
haben und dass man da macht sie
technisch zwei dinge zum einen werden
zwischen geräten ein sogenannter
schlüssel ausgetauscht dieser schlüssel
werden auf den geräten lokal gespeichert
und das hat auch nach allem was wir
wissen total super funktioniert da war
die app auch völlig in ordnung was nicht
funktioniert hat war die war der
abgleich anschließend mit schüsseln von
infizierten menschen wenn ich zum
beispiel jetzt in der abmelde dass ich
infiziert bin wird auf andere geräte der
schlüssel den ich erzeugt habe geladen
und die warnung dass ich ihm dass ich in
der nähe eines infizierten war wird aber
nur dann ausgeübt
wenn die app im hintergrund auf dem
gerät während ich sie gar nicht auf habe
wenn sie daneben feststellte da kommt ja
ein schlüssel rein ich war in der nähe
eines infizierten und das ist das
grundproblem was wir hier haben aber
auch das entscheidende beide genau die
entscheidende aufgabe und die deswegen
ist aber diese hintergrund
aktualisierung so wichtig deswegen noch
mal die nutzer müssen die app
aktualisieren und sie müssen sich
vergewissern dass diese hintergrund
aktualisierung läuft und in der neuen
version der app sieht man das inzwischen
jetzt auch aktiv in den einstellungen
man sieht das auch auf dem iphone ganz
klar man kann in den einstellungen
schauen dass die hintergrund
aktualisierung läuft das müssen die
leute jetzt ganz klar prüfen ob das auch
funktioniert dann geht geht alles seinen
geregelten gang so wie es sein soll
das problem aber vorher war eben dass
diese hintergrund aktualisierung nicht
automatisch passiert ist sondern durch
ein sehr umständlichen glaube 11
schritte umfassenden workaround
ausgelöst werden musste auf diesen
betroffenen geräten und das geht einfach
gar nicht finde ich es wenn ganz kurz
jetzt funktioniert das aber also seit
mittwoch stand jetzt ja deswegen ist es
auch aufgefallen weil jetzt plötzlich
diese auf diesem hintergrund aktuell
lesung funktion aktiv in der app
hingewiesen wurde
das problem vorher war tatsächlich das
problem war da es war auch bei den
entwicklern bekannt ist war beim rk ii
bekannt war aber irgendwo auf den
hilfeseiten ganz weit unten versteckt
und auch die nutzer wurden nicht aktiv
darauf hingewiesen
deswegen hat zwar die app manchmal so
ein bisschen funktioniert wenn man sie
mal geöffnet hat oder so aber eben nicht
denn im hintergrund ich habe das schon
verglichen
dass das so als ob man zu hause eine
eine kamera mit bewegungsmelder hat aber
immer nur alarm bekommt von dieser
kamera wenn man mal aktiv ein schaut
aber nicht wenn sich gerade was vor der
kamera bewegt und das geht natürlich gar
nicht ja ein entscheidender faktor der
jetzt gott sei dank wohl funktioniert
ist wenn stein vielen herzlichen dank
für deinen besuch hier wird's im studio